FOR THAT.
>> THANKS.
>> THANK YOU.
MIRANDA DEVINE, AUTHORITY ON
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP, AUTHOR OF
"LAPTOP FROM HELL," JOINS US.
YOU HAVE BEEN ON PARTS OF THIS
STORY FOR YEARS NOW, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
>> WELL, IT JUST LOOKS LIKE
PROJECTION FROM JOE BIDEN,
DOESN'T IT?
AS USUAL, DEMOCRATS TOOL OF
TRADE TO ACCUSE THEIR OPPONENTS
OF THE VERY SINS THEY ARE
COMMITTING.
IT IS OBVIOUS IN THIS CASE NOW
AND YOU JUST WONDER WHY IT HAS
COME OUT AND WHAT THE TRUE STORY
IS ABOUT THESE CONFIDENTIAL
DOCUMENTS.
BUT AS FAR AS UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA GOES, THERE IS A
LONG INCESTUOUS SIM BIOTIC
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE BIDENS,
JOE BIDEN, YOU KNOW, HIS
GRANDCHILDREN IN THERE, CHILDREN
OF FRIENDS IN THERE, HE TREATED
IT AS HIS OWN LITTLE PLAYPEN AND
WHEN HE STEPPED DOWN FROM BEING
VICE PRESIDENT, HE WAS PAID
ALMOST A MILLION DOLLARS BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA, OR
HE PUT HIS NAME ON THAT SUPPOSED
THINK TANK.
AND IN RETURN, I SUPPOSE HIS
NAME ATTRACTED CHINESE MONEY.
AS YOU JUST SAID, THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY CAME IN FROM CHINA TO THE
UNIVERSITY AFTER JOE BIDEN
OPENED THAT THINK TANK
QUADRUPLED ALMOST, FROM ABOUT
$20 MILLION TO OVER $75 MILLION.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT QUID QUO PRO
AND TALK ABOUT NAOMI BIDEN, THE
CASUAL OFFER FROM PENN PROFESSOR
OF THIS PROPAGANDA TOUR
SPONSORED AND PAID FOR BY THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY WITH
BUSINESS CLASS TICKETS AND
HUNTER SAID GO FOR IT AND ASK
FOR TWO TICKETS SO YOU CAN BRING
YOUR BOYFRIEND.
>> IT IS BEYOND BELIEF AND
HAPPENING OUT IN PUBLIC.
OF COURSE YOU KN